if you want to survive in the future
you've got to produce more than you
consume and this is why civilization
will hopefully keep advancing hi I'm
Nicholas B with reason TV and today
we're very happy and privileged to be
talking with Doug Casey he is an
investment guru to the planet and he's
also the subject of the new book totally
incorrect conversations with Doug Casey
has told to Lois James thank you so much
for joining us document totally
incorrect what what brought this about
why the conversations and why now well
it's just my opinions on what's going on
in the world today although I cover
everything from ancient Rome to drugs to
politics to investments I pretty much
cover the waterfront what is the most
politically incorrect or totally
incorrect thing that you say in the book
well pick a subject any subject I
suggested that the US default on the
national debt in an honest way they're
gonna default on it anyway there's no
question well okay well let's stop for a
second when they're gonna default
eventually what do you mean by that well
there's two ways they can default on it
essentially one is by creating trillions
and trillions of more currency units and
they can pay it off nominal right but
they're worth nothing right so I mean is
weighted away well that's the that's the
that's the way it's honest the dishonest
way but the likely way more likely
they're the way I recommend is to do
with the way our Janina has done it
that's the country that I basically live
in at this point and that's to quite
candidly just tell people we're not
going to give it to you and I recommend
defaulting on the debt because well for
several reasons perhaps the best one is
that I don't think it's correct to make
the next several generations of
Americans indentured servants to pay
back the debt but then if you default on
the debt
that aren't you aren't you sniffing
people now yeah there's now well you're
quite correct let's see who we're
sniffing we're sniffing the people that
have lent the government money and I
think they should be punished for having
financed its destructive minimum
contractors question sorry when
Argentina defaulted and you know kind of
reset its economy you know Argentina is
a small economy relative to the so
that's certainly to the size of the US
but to the global economy what would
happen if they just say you know what
screw it we're not you know we're done
we're starting tomorrow we're starting
with a new currency we're gonna call it
the Kasey and it's going to be a true
hard currency that's backed by reality
right well wrong that would be promises
that would be the first mistake yeah
because it's not a good idea to have a
national currency money is a medium of
exchange and a store of value there's no
necessity for a national currency it
should simply be I'd suggest gold it's
the 1 of 9 you would rather have a I
mean you you would your preferred vision
would be one of competing currencies
particularly private currencies and I
would have to show I mean this happens
anyway sure but they would have to
compete on a market based on what people
think about people who should use
whatever they wish for currency and I'm
of the opinion it's just an opinion that
gold would triumph because it has some
unique benefits it's better than Bitcoin
and so forth all these things perhaps
have a have a place sure do you feel
more optimistic or less optimistic just
about you know where we're gonna be
tomorrow compared to where we are today
yeah well this is a question about human
nature and I have to somewhat
conflicting views one law that I believe
in and I don't believe in most laws but
I believe in Pareto's law the 80/20 rule
and one application of that in my
opinion is that 80% of people are
basically decent get along go on but
we've had a cancer growing in this
geographical area for many years and at
this point it's metastasized and it's
gotten huge these people that we've had
for the last 40 years it's very much
like the Roman Empire
I mean after Augustus they got Tiberius
and everybody was so happy when Tiberius
died but then they got Claudius and and
they got Caligula Oh glad he's dead now
they get Nero right as an exit question
what do you do you say you live mostly
in origin Tina now is that is that the
best solution to go find a place where
you can kind of you know do your own
thing on your own terms and are those
places maybe not in the geographical
United States but are those places
growing more around the planet I like
living outside of the United States
because if you're here in the u.s.
you're especially here in Washington DC
where we are you're in the heart of the
beast it's best to be away from them
physically and living in a foreign
country where you are not a citizen
the government doesn't consider consider
you a piece of its property or the
property of somebody else and you're
treated politely as a visitor who can
leave so you have much more freedom
being in effect a permanent tourist in
that country and most of these foreign
governments don't have the same
interests as the u.s. does look it's of
Argentina for instance the people in
government are mainly interested in
lining their pockets and stealing
they're not terribly interested in
controlling you the way they are here
Doug Casey he is the subject and
speaking voice of the new collection of
conversations totally incorrect thanks
for talking with recent TV pleasure
[Music]